- Le village de Saint-Louis-de-
Gonzague, dans l'arrière-pays
de Carleton-sur-Mer, a été fermé
en 1974. Mais depuis une
vingtaine d'années, le lieu
a été réinvesti, entre autres
par une communauté alternative
qui souhaite vivre autrement.
Cette communauté d'une douzaine
de personnes vit de sa
production maraîchère.
GASPAR LÉPINE, produc. maraîcher
et résident, Saint-Louis-de-Gon.
- Saint-Louis est une mosaïque
villageoise, on pourrait dire.Fe
cette configuration, ça amène
des activités d'entraide...
ou des aou des aou des activités
où les gens aménagent leur spot
à eux comme ils veulent.
- Si la majorité des membres
n'habite pas nécessairement
ensemble, ce n'est pas le cas de
ceux de la communauté du Manoir,
ède un terrain dans la
MRC de Bonaventure. Ils mangent
ensemble et leur assiette est
composée en presque totalité
de produits de leur terre.
Les membres doivent cependantttt
donner 100 % de leurs revenus
extérieurs à la communauté,
ce qui, selon eux, les protège
des contrecoups de l'économie.
VINCENT BLOUIN, membre fondateur
communauté du Manoir
- On est vraiment plus forts
de par le fait qu'on partage
nos revenus, on s'entraide,
puis on arrive aussi beaucoup
à diminuer nos dépenses.
- C'est, selon eux, une façon
de se reavec une vie
qui a plus de sens que la vie
parfois effrénée qui existe
en ville.
SOLANGE LECOT, membre,
communauté du Manoir
- J'allais pas bûcher quand
j'habitais à Montréal, là.
J'avais jamais tenu une
chainsaw. Mais là, astheure,
je suis à l'aise, ça va bien.
Fait qu'il y a vraiment beaucoup
de nouvelles connaissances
que j'ai acquises.
- Ces gens se sont aussi
regroupés pour le partage de
valeurs politiques qui sont,
selon eux, centrales dans
leur mode de vie.
- Ça demande du travail autant
que n'importe quelporte quelpor,
sauf que nous, notre travail,
il reste... il est à nous.
On récupère ce travail-là
à la place d'être déposséd
par des capitalistes.
- Ils es de vivre de
manière alternative n'est pas
une solution à tout.
Encore faut-il apprendre
à vivre ensemble.
MAUDE PRUD'HOMME, résidente
Saint-Louis-de-Gonzague, Qc
- Il y a des luttes qu'on peut
faire là où on est pour pouvoir
faire communauté là où on est,
identifier les entraves...
communauté dans
les différents lieux
qu'on habite plutôt que...
de juste aller ailleurs.
- Certaines communautés
recrutent parfois de nouveaux
membres. Ils prennent cette
tâche au sérieux et vont jusqu'à
imposer aux candidats unepériodt
de les accepter.
Ici Louis Pelchat-Labelle,
Radio-Canada, Carleton-sur-mer.